es ist nun wirklich einige Zeit
vergangen in der ich keine Mystery Boxen
online bestellt habe der Markt hat sich
sicherlich leicht verändert und ich habe
mich gefragt welche Mystery Boxen lohnt
sich noch und welche nicht wir packen
heute mal wieder aus 150 € Media Markt
mit doppeltem Warenwert 200 € Amazon
retour mit mindestens 400 € Warenwert
und eine 500 € Saturn wo natürlich mit
doppelten Warenwert also mindestens 1000
€ viel Spaß und damit herzlich
willkommen zum neuen Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's allen gut ich bin
gespannt ich würde sagen wir verlieren
gar keine Zeit und starten direkt mit
der ersten rein wir haben hier einmal
Amazon dann haben wir hier einmal Saturn
noch mal Saturn und Media Markt glaube
ich ach nee das ist Media Markt
Entschuldigung dann ist das hier beides
noch Saturn Leute bevor wir starten
würde ich euch gerne aber einmal den
Sponsor das heutige Videos vorstellen
und zwar ist das VPN habe ich euch auch
bereits in meinem vorletzten Reisevideo
vorgestellt vielleicht könnt ihr euch
daran noch erinnern hier jetzt
allerdings noch mal weil ein VPN echt
hilfreich sein kann und wegen kurz ins
Flugzeug zurück bisschen ich weiß und
während wir jetzt hier mittlerweile
sogar in der Luft sind kommen
das ist auch eine Premiere ich glaube
ich habe noch nie einen Sponsor im
Flugzeug vorgestellt und zwar nein das
gibt's nicht okay wir haben das Problem
gelöst der sponsort des heutigen Videos
ist CyberGhost VPN CyberGhost hilft euch
im Internet egal ob ihr privat oder
geschäftlich unterwegs seid sicherer zu
surfen dabei wird eure IP-Adresse
verschlüsselt und eure ganzen Daten sind
safe unterwegs außerdem habt ihr
natürlich die Möglichkeit über 40
Streaming Anbieter egal ob Netflix Prime
Video was auch immer überall unbegrenzt
und vor allem uneingeschränkt weltweit
zu nutzen und dadurch dass cybergaust
9000 Server in 91 Ländern besitzt ist
eine zuverlässige VPN Verbindung
eigentlich immer gegeben natürlich kann
ich selber Basti auf dem iPhone
verwenden geht noch am MacBook Windows
PC Android Gerät wie auch immer ich bin
jetzt natürlich gerade im Flugzeug habe
das aber eben schon mal für euch
aufgezeichnet so sieht das aus wirklich
super nutzerfreundlich ihr könnt euch
einfach in irgendein Land einwählen und
Amerika let's go was auch super cool ist
ihr müsst nur einen Account erstellen
und können sieben Geräte gleichzeitig
nutzen also besser geht's eigentlich gar
nicht mit meinem Link den jetzt hier
eingeblendet seht bekommt
85% Rabatt auf CyberGhost zahlen also
ungefähr nur 2 € pro Monat also echt
nicht viel und falls es euch doch nicht
gefällt was ich glaube gibt's noch 45
Tage Geld zurück Garantie also checkt
aus und wir chillen jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen weil dann geht's gleich weiter
der Tag wird noch anstrengend also sowas
habe ich echt lange nicht gemacht ich
freue mich sehr wir starten jetzt mit
der 150 € Media Markt Wundertüte nennt
sich das ja immer noch und die ist jetzt
vom Media Markt Jena da habe ich noch
nie bestellt soweit ich weiß haben wir
doch mal rein ich muss auch sagen ich
habe letztens ein Video gesehen von
Torben Platzer mit dem Stand ich dazu
auch ein bisschen den Kontakt der hat
auch mal Mystery Boxen getestet von
Media Markt Saturn und so weiter und der
hat wirklich einmal auffällig viel
bekommen also da waren Laptop drin
alleine dieser Laptop hat irgendwie über
800 € gekostet und das war einfach viel
zu viel und er dachte sich dann ja
vielleicht kann die mich von YouTube und
deswegen ich bin mal gespannt was bei
mir so drin ist und ob irgendwas drauf
steht ob sich irgendwas besonders lohnt
irgendwas nicht schauen wir einfach mal
oh Gott naja erstmal muss man ja sagen
was relativ positiv ist es ist ziemlich
viel drin die haben auch direkt die
Rechnung das schaue ich mir jetzt geht
es nicht an und insgesamt muss das ja
auf 300 Euro kommen mindestens das wäre
ganz schön okay starten wir erstmal mit
ich weiß doch als ich damals meine erste
Box bestellt habe von Saturn da war auch
Kaffee drin wir haben ja einfach Kaffee
ja alles klar danke dafür 8 €, dann
haben wir als nächstes einmal Hammer
Thermostat Smart Thermostate gar nicht
mal so günstig wow okay ich bin gespannt
hier muss ich jetzt auf jeden Fall auch
mal schauen was von euch rausgehen und
zwar habe ich beim letzten Video in den
Kommentaren gesehen ich soll einfach
Google lens benutzen um die Produkte zu
checken und das machen wir jetzt einfach
mal und haben direkt hier das Thermostat
das gibt's jetzt bei cool blue.de für 40
€ ja damit kann man arbeiten das ist
allerdings der günstigste Preis
ansonsten haben wir auch ja zwischen 35
und 60 € kostet das ungefähr alles klar
Boomer Mini Bluetooth Speaker also
Google lens ist echt Game changer 8 €
super wow chill in the sunshine alles
klar das mache ich doch direkt mal 9,99
€ na ja die Frage ist also gut mein Papa
hört noch CDs aber ich halt nicht und
hier haben wir Mystic Circle alles klar
noch eine CD also das hier zusammen
alles ungefähr 30 ein protection glass
auch nicht viel wert sagen wir mal 15
und dann haben wir hier einmal einen
Wecker von Grundig ich würde mal
schätzen 40 bis 50 € also der kostet auf
Amazon einfach nur 18 €. ja gut ist auch
nur ein Wecker ne warum sollten Wecker
noch so teuer sein und hier geht's
weiter mit ah was ist das denn Hammer
Smart solution WiFi LED Lampe von Hammer
die haben wir gleich viermal ja wenn
eine davon jetzt bei 20 € liegt wäre das
ja ganz gut leider nicht eine kostet 14
€ ja gut 28 sind wir trotzdem bei 56 €,
dann haben wir hier noch irgendwas Mar
Super Mario Lego Batterien und popsocket
der benutzt eigentlich heutzutage noch
popsockets vorbei ich habe mir letztens
wirklich mal gedacht leicht ist das gar
nicht so verkehrt deswegen wollte ich
habe keinen Bock darauf oder nee
wireless vielleicht doch mal ein Zehner
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt hier
haben wir das Highlight Produkt und zwar
ein Galaxy Tab A8 ich habe keine Ahnung
was das kostet gut ich will mich gar
nicht beschweren hier liegen jetzt
wahrscheinlich schon mal so grob
geschätzt 120 €, das heißt dieses Dingen
wird vermutlich 180 Kosten ich denke
damit kommen wir gut hin okay vielleicht
habe ich ja auch zum Glück wie Torben
und das Teil ist einfach Arsch viel wert
nein ist gerade sogar bei Media Markt im
Angebot für 159 €, aber gut eigentlich
kann man sagen bin mir sicher dass das
schnell weggeht ich habe ja für die
ganzen Boxen 150 € bezahlt dass sie
kriegen das vielleicht für 150 auch
wieder los dann habe ich diese ganzen
Sachen über ist doch okay ich kann die
Boxen ja einfach mal nach Stern bewerten
hier gibt's von mir jetzt acht von zehn
Sterne für packen wir das ganze mal
wieder zusammen und wir machen weiter
mit der nächsten Box ich würde sagen
genau hier haben wir jetzt die Amazon
Kiste wir machen weiter mit Amazon 200 €
habe ich bezahlt 400 € Wert soll hier
drin sein mal gespannt das habe ich
übrigens ganz normal bestellt über ebay
weißen Shop die halt Amazon Sachen
verkaufen und vielleicht ganz kurz dazu
ich habe ja auch einen Shop da könnt ihr
auch Amazon Retouren kaufen ich habe
nämlich wieder ziemlich viele Paletten
für mehrere tausend Euro bestellt
Multimedia Haushalt und so weiter und so
fort also wenn euch dafür interessiert
sind auch Bilder und so dabei ist auch
in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt okay
400 € Amazon ich bin mal gespannt wir
haben hier den Karton wir haben hier
eins das ist das denn okay das scheint
irgendwie ein Tisch oder sowas zu sein
ja das sind safe also wenn er
mittlerweile echt vertraut mit so
Retouren aber das sind niemals es sei
denn okay das habe ich noch nicht
ausgepackt also da muss hier in diesem
Paket schon etwas teures drin sein okay
wir starten einfach mal hier mit
italiano das ist ja was ist das ach so
ein Dusch Caddy das Ding kann man in der
Dusche befestigen und dann da sein
Duschzeug und so rein bauen das steht
jetzt leider keine Marke weiß aber alles
noch original eingepackt also
duschkettys Kosten hier bei mir zwischen
40 und 150 €. ich würde mich jetzt echt
wundern wenn Google lens dieses Ding so
erkennen weil ich habe muss ich sagen
echt keine Verwendung dafür und ich habe
jetzt gar keinen Bock das aufzubauen das
wird ja nicht funktionieren wir können
jetzt irgendwelche Stative okay das
verstehe ich auch ich würde einfach mal
schätzen dieses Ding kostet bei Amazon
safe nicht mehr als 50 oder 60 Euro
sagen wir mal 60 € gut gemeinte 60 €,
okay dann machen wir hier weiter wir
haben drei Mal ein Satelliten von
fransat zweimal sehen die ziemlich neu
verpackt aus und einmal auch ziemlich
demoliert bin ich mal gespannt die kenne
ich mich auch nicht wirklich mit aus
schauen wir mal nach sorry ich nehme
alles zurück ein Satellit kostet
tatsächlich bei Amazon 105 €. das ist
echt strong damit hätte ich nicht
gerechnet als Song
ich muss es noch mal doppelt überprüfen
er hat tatsächlich Amazon 105 € auf
Idealo auf 100 € ein Ding davon 100 €
200 €, 300 €, 360 € gut eins ist
demontiert sagen wir mal wir landen
gerade ja UVP sind wir auf jeden Fall
bei 350 € mittlerweile safe angelangt
das heißt hier in dem Paket vermutlich
noch irgendwas drin was ungefähr 50 €
kostet aha ja ich weiß ja nicht eine
Tastatur die aber auf jeden Fall schon
mal benutzt wurde also die sieht gar
nicht schlecht aus moment mal ja doch
das ist die Tastatur wir haben ja eine
Calibur drebo ich glaube es ist eine ist
es eine Gaming Tastatur müssen wir
schauen mal gucken was die für ein Wert
hat okay ich habe sie gefunden kostet
neu bei Ebay 35 €. die ist jetzt schon
einmal er kann sein dass die defekt ist
ich weiß es nicht genau kannst du
vielleicht noch eine Tastatur gebrauchen
von calibor die ist mega ich hätte sonst
auch noch ein paar Satelliten im Angebot
von Franz hat oder auch ganz heiß jetzt
neu im Angebot und zwar ein duschki ja
ja da kannst du dein Shampoo und so
reinstellen
nee zum in die Dusche stellen
stimmt für dich nicht
hört sich gut an okay machen wir 30 Euro
also Leute Amazon retouren sind ja mein
Spezialgebiet ich muss wirklich sagen
okay ich habe dafür jetzt 200 € bezahlt
der Händler hat auf jeden Fall ein gutes
Geschäft gemacht weil wir hier auch
keine Premium Marken dabei haben
trotzdem war es okay ich würde jetzt mal
lieb gemeinte sechs von zehn Sternen
geben dafür mehr ist auf jeden Fall
leider nicht drin aber der erste
Eindruck war schlechter als es jetzt im
Endeffekt war ne so und dann haben wir
jetzt hier noch das größte package und
zwar von Saturn 500 € habe ich bezahlt
für diese beiden wunderschönen Pakete
starten wir einfach mal mit dem
kleineren oder gut es ist gar nicht
unbedingt klein aber ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass hier einfach nur
ein Produkt drin ist ein Staubsauger ich
habe erst vor zwei Wochen für 3000 €,
das waren noch mehr als 2000 €
Staubsauger gekauft also ich hatte bei
mir über 30 Staubsauger naja egal jetzt
habe ich den 31 wir haben einen kurex 7
green von AEG ja das Ding kostet auf
jeden Fall über 200 € schauen wir mal
was sagt Google lens ich hatte sogar
genau den gleichen in einer anderen
Farbe bei mir okay
gut den gibt's gerade bei CHECK24 im
Angebot für 182 alles klar also wir
merken uns dieses Ding kostet 182 das
heißt hier müssen jetzt noch mindestens
800 € Wert drin sein letztes
fangen wir mal mit glaube ich
langweiligeren Sachen an wir haben hier
einmal bibi und Tina für Playstation 5
30 Euro wir haben rainbowski extraction
sagen wir mal auch 30 Euro vielleicht
ein bisschen teurer ich weiß gar nicht
kein Bock nachzugucken contractions
swani und Rugby 18 vom ganz ehrlich 5 €
Rugby 18 schickt mir doch gleich Rugby
11 also bitte das Spiel ist anscheinend
doch 5 Jahre alt oder bin ich blöd
hiermit naja was heißt kann ich mich aus
Spotlight cameras von Arlo das ist echt
eine teure Marke ich habe mir vorstellen
dass die zusammen bei ungefähr 300 €
liegen also erste Eindruck von dem Paket
ist gut ich kann mir vorstellen dass wir
die 1000 € auf jeden Fall knacken dieses
Set so wie ich sie habe kostet bei Media
Markt
489,99 €. das ist schon richtig strong
weil ich habe gesehen wir haben ja noch
Philips User Sachen und zwar eins zwei
hier haben wir einmal Philips Hue E27
Leuchten Kosten 45 € und dann haben wir
hier ein Junge die fification Filter ich
habe nämlich gerade erst gedacht dass es
andere Produkte sind deswegen werden wir
bei einem höheren Preis gelandet aber
gut die Kosten 21 Euro 99 eine Webcam
sag mal 30 Euro noch eine Lampe 15 Euro
ohne realtime Traffic 40 Euro noch ein
paar CDs zusammen in Zehner und haben
wir hier noch ein DJI Motion Controller
ich würde mal schätzen 70 liege ich mal
wieder falsch kostet sogar 150 okay nein
die Box ist stabil wir haben noch eine
Philips Sonicare die ist eigentlich auch
teurer als 100 € und noch eine Maus okay
die muss ich noch checken dann würde ich
einmal schnell im Kopf zusammenrechnen
kostet ungefähr ein Honi das heißt wir
rechnen mal kurz zusammen wir haben hier
100 €. wir haben 115 €
145 € diese Maus was ist die Wert kann
sagen man Zehner 155 € mit dem Ding 40
195 € plus 150 € landen aber bei 345 €
schon mal okay dann hier das Zeug drei
Mal CDs 350 die Spiele alle zusammen
sagen wir mal 60 ungefähr sind wir bei
110 ungefähr sagen wir mal 410 430 475
plus das Dingen knapp 500 landen wir
schon mal bei knapp 1000 Euro und das
sind nicht nur die UVP Preise ich habe
hier überall so halbwegs realistische
Preise angesetzt die ich dafür auch noch
bekommen könnte klar man muss auch
irgendwo loswerden aber das meiste davon
geht auf jeden Fall safe weg ich spreche
aus Erfahrung auch wenn natürlich viele
sagen so Saturn Media Markt Wundertüten
lohnt sich unterm Strich meistens nicht
stimmt auch allerdings kann ich sagen
diese Box lohnt sich auf jeden Fall und
die Media Markt Wundertüte lohnt sich
auch halbwegs man macht zumindest keinen
Verlust außer man ist blöd und den
Staubsauger für 180 habe ich noch
vergessen das heißt wir landen bei knapp
1 2 was man im allerbesten Fall dafür
bekommen kann gut das ist schon echt
strong ey also diese Box bekommen von
mir auf jeden Fall 9,5 von zehn Sterne
nicht zehn aber die ist echt super also
ich bin echt zufrieden damit kann man
absolut nichts gegen sagen Leute vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen nächste Woche gibt's
dann wieder ein Reisevideo ich hoffe ihr
freut euch drauf abonniert sehr sehr
gerne den Kanal und ja
haut rein ciao